our games are famous for choices and
consequences for mature storylines and
for this grim and gritty mood in the
universe of The Witcher basically and
all those things we want to bring to
Gwent as well
if you've played The Witcher 3 you've
probably heard of Gwent either you
avoided it like a plague or you ended up
sinking just as much time in the mini
game as you did with the main game if
you played it as much as I did then you
probably already know that CD Projekt
RED is developing a standalone
free-to-play game but if Gwen is just as
foreign to use the core at desert here's
a little lesson Gwen is a card game
based on a game in the book called
barrel the mini game was first
introduced in The Witcher 3 Wild Hunt
and it relies on bluffing and resource
management at the start of the game you
draw ten cards and unless you have a
card that allows you to draw more this
is going to be your hand for the
remaining rounds similar to card games
like hearthstone or Magic the Gathering
players collect cards and build decks
that cater to a certain strategy and The
Witcher 3 players could eventually pick
from five different decks each with
different play styles what's immediately
noticeable is how much cleaner the UI
looks those who played Gwent in The
Witcher 3 will still feel at home but
everything is a fresh coat of paint on
it the board is more stylish the cards
look sleek and more detail has been put
into the animations
what's also noticeable is how the
nilfgaard deck is missing it will be
coming eventually but as of now it still
needs more tweaking and balancing Oh
manage Thank You friendly card games are
difficult to balance in general and went
was done basically for the single-player
only because as you pointed out and
which are free basically you thought
only AI right so it didn't have to be
well balanced against the other players
but Gwent isn't just a single-player
game this time around one of the main
draws the standalone game is online
multiplayer and as I'm sure you know
balancing for a multiplayer game is a
whole nother ballgame wood
we have to rebalance everything we have
to add a lot of abilities because a lot
of cards in which our wealth comes were
just beautiful cards we had to add rows
to the deck building because you might
remember in which one wall can't you
could put all your hero units in your
deck and that could have been your deck
right while they are resistant to most
effects from the cards and the effects
on the board you know it makes it kind
of boring and basically both players
only play heroes so basically we limited
this to Hall right now even though each
faction has a different overarching
strategy there's still plenty of room
for experimentation the monsters for
example that our cool decks that are
built around whether that's summon units
the board when you play whether and they
get stronger and so on but also that our
next its focus on a wild card for
example like putting a lot of them
making them stronger
bringing copying them even like over you
know over swarming your opponent
basically with world huh I found another
example of this in the Skellig attack
one way to play the deck is with your
graveyard in mind there are a number of
cards that buff depending on how many
cards are in your graveyard and there
are certain cards that Dublin strengthen
they are resurrected if that's not your
style there are also plenty of Skellig
ax cards that increase in strength along
there on the battlefield one card in
particular even transformed into a hero
after staying alive a turn these play
styles aren't exactly new when it comes
to card games but because Gwent relies
so much on resource management sending a
precious card to the graveyard hoping
that it will pay off later ups the risk
and reward
as much fun as Gwent is i think what has
been most excited for this game is the
story mode
CD Projekt RED is known for their
stories and Gwent is no different
ultimately Gwent has five different
campaigns for each of the factions
basically the idea is to make separate
campaigns for each and every one of them
so you will play a different protagonist
and everyone every one of those is
tailored uniquely around the specific
faction the developer is still
tight-lipped on the specifics but they
will feature mature storylines that
we've come to expect difficult and
morally great decisions and characters
we've come to love in the slice of the
campaign I saw we played as Geralt
exploring an open area interacting with
towns and ruins in order to meet new
characters collect cards and of course
battle opponents interestingly enough
you won't only be playing as the white
wolf Geralt is not the protagonist this
time around so we get to explore
different perspectives when doing these
campaigns you know we can present you
with different kinds of choices than you
would have in The Witcher games because
again some things Geralt will never do
but some of our characters that we use
as protagonists for this one basically
they have totally different perspective
on things
cards in the single-player campaign are
more than just cards you stumble across
the cards that you find and earn along
the way are intertwined with characters
and events the card battles are
symbolizing the actual battles in the
game right so contrary to what hunt
where you basically those were little
card games and we're winning cards from
these people and so on in here it's more
like like I said before they are joining
your army and it's like they symbolize
actual people and to some degree you can
also talk with them because some of
those characters are important and you
might want to uncover the bloodlines and
you know you might want to know more
about them and so on
however only the first campaign will be
available at launch but the rest will
follow is paid expansions
not your lucky day so is Gwent for you
if card games aren't your thing then
maybe not but I wouldn't write it off
entirely
CD Projekt RED has high ambitions for
this free-to-play card game and if
you're aching to spend more time in the
witcher universe then this game will
definitely be worth your time
unfortunately there isn't a release date
for Gwen but the closed beta kicks off
on October 25th so make sure to sign up
for that
for more on Gwen and The Witcher stay
tuned to game spot